so this is a big night because it's like
the first time ever like the name here I
have screaming fans here yes that's
always a nice thing to get out of the
car people scream at you it feels heck
you movie premiere it to be honored by
it by all the actors that I admire and
some I don't know is just such a such an
exciting night you know I don't know
what's gonna happen when don't get two
tonne of these things anymore we'll just
have to make things up to dress up for
YouTube at the SAG Award
[Music]
I was just sitting there watching the
other actresses I mean I was so I you
know they're amazing okay I was just in
1999 et was with a starstruck 23 year
old up-and-coming actress named Angelina
Jolie she took home her first SAG
statuette for Gia
and this epic stars used to be like us
moment from backstage I have a mess i
curled my own hair today and I had to
get four different sets of curlers I had
like call her I was like mom I had half
my head done I ran out of curlers I
didn't call my mom and she had to go to
like drifty and pick up curlers and I
was just waiting and it was really so I
made it through and I'm here 1998 was 27
year old Matt Damon's first year at the
SAG Awards he was nominated alongside
his Good Will Hunting co-star Robin
Williams she's nerve-racking for me a
lot of people here are you gonna be
ready for all this no no do you ever
just sit in your room and go
PT's learned over the years you never
quite know just what the stars will say
the moment they step off stage you can
use the words that you couldn't use on
the stage right now go ahead yes I just
overcome thank you oh that was exciting
I finally have a boyfriend okay you know
I'm gonna be really nice and I'm not
gonna go there
no I'm gonna cry again it's just a big
deal to me I'm just sweating and nervous
at least I start shaking I've never had
one of these 2006 all right next year we
want the best romantic ensemble what's
going through your head right now I
can't my name I'm gonna try
[Music]